hahaha
[Music]
hey you're gonna have to um do you have
something to break because you're gonna
be mad when you hear this you're gonna
need to break up these Chopsticks yeah
yeah okay is it about traffic or it's
about Jiu Jitsu it's about bikers you're
not gonna like it this is like right
this is gonna hit you pretty hard so
it's about us clients Maybe
no I love my clients is the homeless guy
in front of your house okay hold this
dude Antonio Lopez submits like 50
articles every time on the article
suggestion on Discord so here's one of
the ones that he thinks there's one
about house Bula uh it there's a popular
YouTube channel right and it's uh it
shows a bunch of dash cam crashes and
Road raid road rage incidents and um
it ended up being ran by this married
couple in Yucaipa they're the ones that
own this like uh YouTube channel that's
like Arizona California I'm done turns
out that uh turns out that these road
rage incidents and these dash cam
crashes that are being caught on camera
and like posted to the thing are
actually being caused intentionally by
them
wow it's a supply demand thing
wait you wait not yet not yet I [__]
hate fake prankster not yet so not only
that but they're using these uh these
crashes to not only post on YouTube but
also to collect on the insurance
payments oh wait hold on wait you're
gonna want to snap it after this WOW
Yucaipa people got con artist huh turns
out they were also
um charged with child endangerment
because they would have their kid in the
car during all these videos there you go
foreign
that was a Jujitsu break that was
[__] that was that was a lot of force
I was [__] dick none come back dude
pretty good man you didn't make the
noise though you gotta make them
yeah that's my that's my balls don't hit
back how crazy is that man it sounds
like they are desperate for money
Devil's Advocate it's kind of a good
idea right yeah but how do they keep
getting away with it like I feel like
after two or three they just keep break
checking people basically
most of them ah most of them yeah are
you kidding just for Content they're
breaking [__] breaking people to make
them piss so that they get road rage
guns dude their necks must be fun just
for content and for also for the
insurance because like you know if
somebody hits you from like behind it's
like 99 their fall exactly are they like
always like oh this world got so many
bad drivers look at how many uh
accidents we get into us all day we're
not the [__] yeah we're not causing
it how many how many accidents do they
get into do they have like one viral
video a week they so far they've
confirmed about 50 videos new videos
every Wednesday and Friday that's them
do you like them I hate them
he the the guy on the right looks like
he's got a lot of sun yeah
it looks like fake sun he looks like a
desert man yeah he's a desert guy he
looks like he gets orange tanning so
yeah the the channel has been deleted
like all those videos are gone but
how did they get delete them or did
YouTube uh I don't know how they got
caught I feel like there's easier ways
to make money dude I really hate like
fraud type [__] I almost wish like if
someone were to rob me just put a gun on
my face and ask for my money I'll give
it to you than to [__] like Swindle
me you know and like play with me and
[__] but they're afraid of violence but
then it's more honorable that way but
they were up front they were doing
actual road rage stuff like the the guy
is also charged with assault with a
deadly weapon because in some of the
videos he's the one that's like fighting
Jesus so he'll fight people on the side
of the road so he he antagonizes he's
good for the content you know and then
he has [__] ready just in case
yeah and the whole thing is just to like
film it yeah crazy right Jesus does it
mention like how much money they've been
able to get from like insurance or
anything like that doesn't it doesn't it
seems like a couple that involves a lot
of meth in their motivation yeah yeah
definitely meth motivated it doesn't say
how much money but it does say that he
has 11 felony counts of insurance fraud
that's probably gonna amount to quite a
bit Jesus dude this guy's going away
forever where's Yucaipa
let me look it up I feel like it's close
to Joshua Tree or some [__] because
every time I hear these random
California towns I feel like they're
just desolate with like three people
still living there and they only have
meth labs it's uh past Redlands it's
like Riverside
it's between it's between Redlands and
Beaumont because whenever I think of
that I'm like the only kind of jobs they
have is a tow truck driver IE yeah for
real yeah so desert Town yeah yeah they
only got tow truck driver as a as a job
and then they're just like that's why
they gotta do [__] like this because
they don't have money out there yeah
yeah it's San Bernardino yeah it's like
some Tumbleweed situation where you
drive through like when you go to road
trips that's exactly what it looks like
like who the [__] lives there and it's
like a boarded up house and [__] you
ever think that when you go through the
desert in California and all of a sudden
you're driving and there's like three
homes and then you're like before Amazon
and all that how do they get groceries
yeah I want to watch everyone everyone
every time I [__] pump gas at Barstow
I want to ask everyone how did you end
up here what are you doing over here
trying to go to Vegas didn't make it
I'll tell you what what's up some people
are [__] weird right my little
brother's weird he's just a weird human
being he just wants to live off the
[__] grid right he's like out of the
Air Force now he like wants to live on
the land and all that kind of [__] like
once up for some reason live next to his
in-laws we bought land next to his
in-laws and he's like building a [__]
house out there or that's the plan
where's out there Missouri like in the
middle of nowhere like [__] like
swampland Missouri yeah dude but he
loves it but stuff like that I
understand I don't understand being in
between two awesome places
did I mean if it's like oh I'm gonna
move to [__] Tennessee because I'm
gonna get these fields or Wyoming I'm
like cool I get it you're literally
going away from everywhere when people
go I'm going away from everywhere but
I'm kind of between two big plays I'm
like you're not doing anything yeah like
your purpose the closest thing to you is
a [__] gas station and a Del Taco
dude this is how like sorry if you're
from Yucaipa but in this list of 15 best
things to do in Yucaipa yeah like seven
of them are churches one of them's the
post office one of them City Hall and
the other one's the library
holy [__] there's [__] that eat
humans in cities like this yeah for sure
there's a whole character like this on
GTA his name is Trevor yeah 100 and it's
it's a [__] stereotype Dude you go to
these towns yeah the most trailers yeah
the California hillbillies with three
teeth dude watch out the Whitakers yeah
okay I'm foreign
so like let's say they go to jail right
where are they in the [__] food chain
in like a jail like obviously you got
like if your child molesters and stuff
like that are gonna get destroyed and
beat the [__] up right away Troopers are
getting wrecked but the Frog guys yeah
[__] yeah the front guys are gonna get
[__] with because they're not
honorable enough to actually do a real
crime so if they're already [__] made
everyone's gonna be punking the [__] out
of them in jail they probably aren't
gonna go into the same I don't know
[__] made is a funny word it's a white
collar crime I don't know no one's
really getting prosecuted these days huh
that's true they're gonna let them go
yeah I think they're gonna have a great
time in jail dude I think they're gonna
be it's gonna be [__] they probably
have a lot of friends probably I could
be like a hotel they're both out on bail
so I mean it can't be super serious
right it's it's [__] Newsom land
everyone's getting yeah luckily for them
it's still Newsom lead yeah productive
with their viability like the like the
um like the cranberry juice guy it was
the cranberry juice with the Fleetwood
Mac he went viral and dog face yeah
we're born and drinking yummy juice
that's true yeah I bet they he is an
anomaly though yeah they're great
checking on a skateboard is very
interesting
[Laughter]
you might deserve the insurance on that
one could be good content yeah it is
crazy though to think like how many
times you've seen like dash cam video
things that are viral and you didn't
really think like oh is this like an
intentional thing for Content my
favorite ones are the ones like in
Russia where they pretend yeah where
they do like yeah they flop yeah I love
that [__] dude I saw one the other day
and it was on the 118 and it was a it
was like a truck kind of like your truck
as big as yours but the tire flew off oh
yeah and the car [__] flew in the air
it hit a key up
shot up in the air like 20 feet and
landed and the driver was fine yeah
completely fine but imagine you're just
driving your car just explodes up I know
that was that was wild
like a movie scene yeah one of the
funniest things is like thinking that
for Cinema it costs so much money to
replicate that example
and that was just one tire yeah
but man yeah that was that was actually
really cool looking it was cool
especially because the guy survived do
you guys all have dash cams by the way
no I need to get one yes yes get one
hundred percent is there a brand you
recommend Ryan's saying it like it's a
[__] entertaining thing no because
well yeah it's entertaining and also
like you don't have to worry about
someone saying it was your fault if
something happened does it just like
like let's say if I'm not next to a car
if someone smacks it does it just start
does it just turn on yeah it's on all
the time yeah it depends on which brand
you get you get you can even get the
cheapest one on Amazon for like 30 bucks
and then that thing their sensors
constantly recording yeah and it deletes
after what 24 hours well from for mine
it just deletes when the card's full so
it'll like fill up the card for like
days and days and days and then just
write over it or something yeah like
once you have motion detect does it have
audio inside my car yeah you can do that
yeah like the I have some that it points
both ways so it's filming the back and
the front or for like Uber drivers they
have like a belligerent the one that I
have it's pointing front and then I have
another camera in the back for the back
oh so then the the back windshield shows
like if anyone rear-ends me or anything
like that why don't you want them to
have audio in your car because if you
heard the things I said in my car
like what are you like yeah you know
dude what sign was that what sound was
that what are you talking about because
you got crazy road rage and you say like
a lot of bad words let's say some guy
hits you but the footage is you singing
Vanessa Carlton like making my way down
like are you just like hey dude just
let's forget this thing
just forget it don't worry about it yeah
want to get this dash cam [__] with
audio no there's no reason to not have
it they're so cheap dude yeah I think
it's good because I almost got hit twice
yesterday
for reals yeah yeah just someone I was
in someone's blind spot and almost one
of my was it Vanessa Carlton I was sick
of my heart out too making my way
downtown it's one of those things where
like it's a night and day difference
between like because your insurance is
going to try everything they can to not
pay you for the thing right and then
their insurance is gonna try everything
they can so one of you just has a dash
cam that just settles it yeah that's
true you know what I mean that sounds
you sound like a veteran so I'm gonna
listen
can you do it like a body cam for a cop
though like let's say you have a dash
cam it's recording but it is kind of
your fault you like delete that [__]
right away you don't you you and there's
no reason that you have to provide your
footage
I drive so much it's probably my best
interest yeah
Nick
hey me too
they're cheap dude
[Music]